We're talking about your reasons why you
dislike Paul.
Okay, let's So, is Paul's words in the
Injil? Yes, Paul's words is part of the
gospel, yes.
Oh, so now Paul's books are part of the
Injil, too. Yeah, even your even your
even your Muslim scholars thought the
same, that the the entire New Testament
as as the
Why would they think the same when Paul
goes against God? That makes no sense.
If that's the case, then why do your
Islamic scholars count Paul as a
messenger of Jesus that Jesus sent out
along with Peter? When Jesus said to his
disciples, "Who will be my helpers in
the cause of Allah?" ALLAH. UH-HUH. And
the disciples say, "We will be helpers
in the cause of Allah." And Jesus said
So, these messengers of Jesus
are actually also messengers of
Finish it. They're not messengers of
God. AH!
COME ON, MAN.
HEY, what's up? Peace. Peace.
Pretty good. How are you? I'm good, man.
I'm good. Good. I like that you're uh
you got a different topic today. Yeah,
shout out to One on One, man. He this I
stole this topic from him. It's a good
one.
I mean, I've seen this topic before, but
people don't want to be honest about it.
So, do you want to be honest about it?
I'm always honest. All right. So,
without running
let's talk about Paul and why we
dislike him.
Well, we'll go one reason at a time.
Okay. First premise, he went against the
everlasting circumcision that God put in
place. Did he? Yes.
Okay. He went against the everlasting
circumcision that God put in place. And
so, for him going against circumcision,
that makes him a false messenger? Yes.
Okay.
All right. I grant that to you. Can you
show me where
where Muhammad mentioned circumcision in
the Quran? Wait, so why are you running
to Muhammad? I'm not. I'm just I'm just
holding your standard.
You are. You are literally running right
away. You can't even address the
everlasting circumcision claim. I'm just
I'm just saying it. You said let's be
honest about it, right? Right. So, if
you can't refute it, that means he's
false. Well, it's it's not about me
refuting. It's just about, you know, us
being us having equal standards. When
you say that you have that you're
applying a standard onto me
then this standard should also apply to
you. Do you agree? The standard of
circumcision does apply to us. I don't
I'm not sure what you're talking about.
Good. Where? What do you mean, where?
Can you show me in the Quran where
Muhammad preached circumcision? Again,
why are we running to the Quran?
Well, you're using this as a standard to
say that Paul's a false messenger. So,
I'm seeing if you're consistent.
Yeah, but Paul's not in the Quran. Oh,
so Muhammad is, though, right? But we're
talking about Paul.
Well, we're talking about your reasons
scared to defend Paul?
about your reasons why you dislike Paul.
why you're doing this if you can't
We're talking about your reasons why you
dislike Paul.
Yes, I just told you he went against
God. Why would I listen to someone that
went against God?
I got you, Chillbates. So, whoever goes,
for example
whoever goes against the circumcision
covenant, they are against God and
therefore a false messenger. That's what
you said. OKAY, I GOT YOU. That's the
standard that you set on Paul. I'm going
with you.
Where did Muhammad preach circumcision?
Where did he not preach circumcision?
All right, give me one place where he
did. Give me one circumcision.
This makes no sense. Can you give me one
place where Muhammad
about Paul. I I thought you were trying
to talk about Paul, bro. Can you give me
one place where he did?
not being honest. So, so you can't
answer, huh? So, did did Muhammad peace
be upon him teach against circumcision?
Can you Can you show me where he
affirmed it? Uh okay, hold on.
Okay. It might be in Hadith if it's not
in Quran.
Hadith? Shouldn't it be in the word of
God? Again
we're talking about Paul, right?
We're talking about your reasons why you
dislike Paul. Okay, let's So, is Paul's
words in the Injil? Yes, Paul's words is
part of the gospel, yes. Oh, so now
Paul's books are part of the Injil, too.
Yeah, even your even your even your
Muslim scholars thought the same, that
the the entire New Testament as as the
Why would they think the same when Paul
goes against God? That makes no sense.
If that's the case, then why do your
Islamic scholars count Paul as a
messenger of Jesus that Jesus sent out
along with Peter? A messenger of Jesus?
Mhm.
What are you talking about? What
scholar? Please, show me. Okay, okay,
okay.
You asked, all right.
Geez, geez, eat a pita. All you had to
do was ask where I'm getting this from.
Golly. Let me show you
where your scholars quote Muhammad as
saying Paul is a messenger of Jesus that
Jesus sent out with Peter and others.
Okay? Okay. Okay. This doesn't help you.
Okay, we'll see. Like he was a messenger
of Jesus, not of God. Like what does
that even matter, though?
We shall Oh, man. This is why you
shouldn't debate, bro. You cannot ever
defend your own topic. Man, that's
tough. Like all you do is run to Islam
every time I debate you. This is all you
ever do.
I know. I know. I know you know. It's
okay. All right. You ready now? You
ready now? So, Paul has been refuted.
Well, I guess you're refuting Muhammad
then. You ready? No. How do I refute
Muhammad if Muhammad
for me to read you the source? Huh?
Huh? Are you ready for me to read you
the source? This doesn't help you. We're
talking about
ready for me to read you the source,
Chillbates? I I already told you
messenger of God is different than
messenger of Jesus. Disciples were
messengers of Jesus. Oh, so they're not
messengers of God by default? Because
Jesus said
Disciples? Jesus says, "Who will be my
helpers in the cause of who?" And who is
Jesus peace be upon him on behalf of
according to the Bible, brother?
Finish it for me. Your Quran says,
"Remember when Jesus said to his
disciples, 'Who will be my helpers in
the cause of Allah?" ALLAH. UH-HUH. And
the disciples say, "We will be helpers
in the cause of Allah." And Jesus said
messengers of Jesus
are actually also messengers of Finish
it. They're not messengers of God. AH!
COME ON, MAN. COME ON, MAN.
So
You can't You can't make this up, man.
So, did Jesus peace be upon him get
words from God what to say as
commandment?
According
to your Quran, yes. Nope. According to
the Bible, brother. Your Quran says that
the disciples of Jesus that Allah
himself gave them revelation. Did you
know that? Through Jesus, yes.
say through Jesus. Bro, it's talking
about through Jesus. That's where they
got their revelations. What are you
talking about?
a second. It's Okay, let's let's let's
do this really quick.
Jesus was from God. I'm not going to,
you know, like I'm it's not like he
wasn't from God. Mhm. But he like was
commanded to speak things on behalf of
God. Well, first let me do this. All
right. It says in the Quran
I'mma read you I'mma read you your
source, okay? This is Ibn Ishaq, chapter
Yes, run run from the Bible that you
can't prove. Your Quran says that the
disciples received revelation, chapter
5, verse 111. Just keep that in your
pocket for yourself, okay?
And and who is it talking about?
Watch this. Watch this. Here it is.
Wait. Wait.
Wait. Wait. What's the context? It's I'm
about to give it to you. I'm about to
give it to you. Give me the context,
bro. You can't I'm about to give it to
you, habibi. Just listen. Look.
Give it a shot. Page 653. Yeah, you're
running. Those whom Jesus, son of Mary,
sent. So, who did he send? We're about
to find out. Both disciples and those
who came after them. Oh, so there were
disciples Jesus sent and he also sent
those who came after disciples. Tough.
Let's see here.
After them in the land were Peter, the
disciple, and Paul with him. Whoa. Wait,
hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold
on.
He can't say He can't mean that. He
can't mean that Paul was sent directly
by Jesus. No way, right? Bro, what does
that have to do with God? This only
helps you when you say Jesus is God.
Like don't you understand that you're
not doing anything for yourself by
running from the Bible? Thanks for
coming. Yeah, that's what I thought.
Again, what is that? 40 times, bro?
That's 41.
That's 41. That's 41. Thanks for coming,
bro. Thanks for coming. Man. Man, oh
man, oh man.